life on the road it's whose taco tangra
course representing guns and these
flights canceled flights running with
the run germ blacklists bounced checks
great Bachelorette pumps in the front
making out for your side and headlights
doing no more missing merge turn drive a
rental car has another megachurch Jinju
skis vagina Fister cell phone is gone
one big law and or
Oh
look I feel super I got a pen I know a
bottle of our how many how many
questions you get from we have a lot of
stuff to do today what are we doing we
are answering listeners questions
listeners of the road stories podcast
hey listen question sure am I gonna be
mad no okay connect how I know Mike cuz
i know i've met him but I just don't
remember how okay how did you meet Mike
I don't know I'm asking you well that's
not how this works so you met at the
improv just at the improv yeah I feel
like we met through something like about
this comedy circles probably engl those
probably it yeah neither of you or
shabbos mingle okay I'm talking to you
Jews hey what the so thanks for tuning
the road stories podcast everybody i'm
your host marie valeriano coming to you
from the valeriano podcast studios no
longer coming from the all things comedy
studio where I've been for the last I
don't know four or five episodes why
would you leave your house and put on
pants but not that I don't love all
things comedy that's where I do my pod
curve but you have such a nice sweet
setup and you love to look at me without
pants on yeah haha so why are you or I
mean what's the deal um I just it's a
but I like the studio I like to go there
I like okay I come in I dive record I
leave they send it to me I post it here
I gotta set up I gotta test you'd like
to leave your family it gives you the
impression that you're actually working
I like to get away why are you are hot
is it I'm hot like hi how are you felt
like you live in Los Angeles and Weber
oh god no cure sorry cos my to talk it's
the carousel ton of it show holy crap
one two three four how's this are you
better I thought you will feel alright
I'm sorry you're rambling on about
yourself again was there something an
heiress trying to give you an analogy by
the way listener Michael kaat said kira
soltanovich is my favorite come on I
swear to you what's his last name khat
KO t.o got like Kira come lie on my cut
okay not a common name no cut there's a
Greg Kot who was a well-known music
reviewer for the Chicago Tribune oh yeah
Michael are you blesses Michael Connor
you uh related to greg kot to greg kot
maybe how many cops could there be
appears have cod is the real last name
can we all just why wouldn't come had
shortened yeah Michael Jacob Kotowski
but they don't shorten it down to three
wert letters delay of course they do ma
my wife's name was so fun opolis or
something like that and it sort of does
it so freeze that's a made-up why didn't
they shorten yours holy crap because we
didn't immigrate in the 40s we yeah
thanks well your parents just came over
your parent Oh your parents are off the
boat that's right no it took TWA first
of all i was born in here as an anchor
baby gotcha i'm an anchor baby are you
from the former Yugoslavia you know it
was hitting speedy I seen it's VI ch
well yeah that's the American used to be
caught and then we lengthened it to
Sultana [ __ ] cuz it rolled off the
tongue okay of electronics in front of
you that you're gonna do a radius bit
take sorry I just wallow now they
swallowed you're an idiot traffic I love
that I love that that was so stupid and
great LOL you're an idiot and you're
stupid or compliments okay sure yeah yes
I'm telling my son no daddy loves you
when he tells you you ruined my life we
have so much to do to do today and uh we
have to get on it because uh my wife
made pizza and I'm hungry okay so first
of all uh kira soltanovich is here mike
siegel thank you very much you people
are like early these people again
they're on the show all the time but I
there's a reason I brought them on here
and we'll get to that in a second but
first announcements good all things
comedy see what's going on over there
I'm there's a lot of great podcast I'm
sure we got some shows coming up I got a
call about a show at the comedy store
did you get a call about that or
anything like that I'm sure you will
awkward I'm sure you will
what show let me finish there was no
show party they're having at Marie V on
Twitter go ahead follow me on Twitter
Marie valero calm has new tour dates so
I'm in town till June but June I am gone
all of june la jolla i will be i'll be
headlining la jolla in where we April
May yeah in May so I have special
tickets for red stories listeners I have
a deal for Road stories listeners and
i'll post that on the Facebook page and
let you guys know when those goes up and
if you haven't like the Facebook page
don't be a douche like us on the
Facebook page there's a lot of good
things i'll be showing sets of Kira and
Mike what one of my permission was yeah
it's the internet suckit if I'm not
buying uh the killer's new album and i'm
downloading it for free i'm not buying
your special song special tickets for
the like this show and i'll come june
i'll be at the purple onion I'll have a
ticket deals for the road stories
listeners up there also and then going
back to old sac yeah I'm back laughs on
living have you been up there in a while
I have not I'm not there in six years
easy Wow easy nobody laughs unlimited my
goal in Sacramento no it is about the
same okay I says it all being bad no it
wasn't bad no it's fine i remember being
okay yeah now the city of Sacramento Oh
saddle Larry Larry's a sweetheart Oh
Larry Mangiamo sound like that honey
really hot back a cot back if I know sm
I was up there I get oh maybe well right
after the economy crashed in Sacramento
is the capital thank you you're welcome
of California what yes not of and
everything was closed yeah everything
was closed down man all the government
offices the the the small was half-empty
just have closed down shops mandatory
furloughs for government workers every
Friday you get to take off whether you
like it or not it was a bad scene so our
hearts are with the people of Sacramento
we wish them the best and we wish that
they'll be at the comedy club june
fourth fifth and sixth ah that's it then
I'm off to the Middle East and then no
so if i have any listeners in bahrain
come on out really we going there with
um I don't know who the other two comics
are okay oh wait no Steve uh Steve's
Simone's amox alone yeah I only worked
with him once he's great yes look I just
sweetheart it he's like super uh very
handsy what I don't have boobies no he's
not he's an absolute sweetheart okay I
only have one showroom he seems uh
annoyingly positive he's a very positive
yeah yeah alright hate him and then the
other guy ever met them in the other guy
don't know it's gonna be a three-man
show ya gonna hit Bahrain Kuwait
djibouti Oh which I didn't even know is
an actual country I thought it was just
for mold Warner Brothers cartoons yeah
but it's an actual country and capital
of djibouti djibouti it is really yeah
yeah really sweet is a city called
djibouti yes in Djibouti yep yeah where
do you live djibouti djibouti oh I would
say that every day if I could what
street and you Kenny hahaha djibouti
avenue um don't know that's not all the
announcements oh there's more there's
more wait there's more gentlemen if only
if we had Tony thaxton on drums I am
announcing the winners of find the Pope
in the pizza pie contest no the UH
anyone find the Pope in the don't about
nothing really Saturday Lester's game
saturday live the great guy father Guido
Sarducci oh I did a show with him once
oh really hmm in San Francisco my home
as father Guido or wise oh that's
hilarious yeah how did he do he did his
father Guido yeah okay I just don't
water I just spilled water everything's
fine everything's fine yeah there's no
problems here cuz you want to get my
t-shirt wet you just have to ask
I gotta close the window she'll be
sweating enough in a minute continue
your father Guido Sarducci uh five
minutes of Guido Sarducci No thank God
15 yeah little that goes a long way yeah
you get it after just things thanks
thanks for cleaning up I just now I know
it's like to have sex with Murray he
just brought an awkwardly large towel
and just like wiped and then left the
towel at my feet I don't clean it up I
let it I let it lay there for the
memories happy Anniversary honey
remember the last night called was
playing in our bed say it again my 8
month old uh-huh was playing in our bed
and just like a little bit of spit up
not a lot okay Bart and I was like ah
cleaned up the stain and I was like
remember we used to have different
stains in this bed my husband and I are
just the six-month said it's in six
month old no my husband oh yeah and he
was like I know those were the days yeah
now it's spit up now you know when your
periods coming to you that sustains
we're talking about right yes okay
period stains right oh yeah all right
good we're gonna cut all of this out
gagging on a demon recoil you're
recording no no I've been recorded yet
now that's why it doesn't give you
headphones ya know right happening the
announcement for the winners of the free
t-shirt giveaway yeah pretty sure give
away a free t-shirt giveaway for people
who wrote a new review of the itunes of
on the itunes wrote a review of the road
stories podcast and nonnative review yes
it has to be positive okay I was the
that was the caveat this sucks yeah you
don't get over to shirt alright so we're
going to go with by the way you're gonna
have to email me if I say your name and
give me your name and address cuz I'm
only going off your iTunes name so you
know have you have an itunes itunes ID
so i'm gonna i'm only going off that so
i don't know your illness so balls deep
67 there so yeah back door mama 73 mom
wrote a review he loves the show
she loves the show man I didn't even
know you could smell right do your due
to pressure braces are making you very
angry you look impression your mother
your they're making it very bitter do an
impression of your mother as I told you
see I'm not I might it's like Dana
Carvey nobody does an impression at
George Bush you do an impression of Dana
Carvey I've just done an impression
Akira doing an impression of her mother
uh so in 1m Rittenhouse 84 I really
appreciate your review and I and I think
you he started listen to me when I had
off the cuff with bowling ball you guys
have both of them were guests on the
siriusxm show weren't you I think so
yeah yeah pretty shirt party I'm pretty
sure so I want to thank you he started
listening started listening to the show
after that so email me you can go
through Marie valeriano calm you can hit
me on the facebook page or you can hit
me at comics on safari @ gmail.com for
your t-shirt so in rittenhouse 84 thank
you so much for your uh beer review also
ZD 37 the big winner here's ed 37 he
says one of them one of my most favorite
podcasts he also get a grammar education
along with that t-shirt always hilarious
marinas guests stories give a
perspective of being a road comedian I'd
never know about without this podcast so
he's talking about you guys also oh
let's know ZD 37 hit me an email through
merveilleux com uh [ __ ] em [ __ ] em Emma
yeah chem life on the road I love
hearing the stories of the comics tell
about where they have had to perform
it's almost unbelievable some of the
things that go on fights terrible crowds
at gigs more terrible crowds and pouring
to an empty room all those stories from
mike siegel yeah hilarious zinger so
buff chem go ahead hit me up for your
t-shirt
and the last one wasn't even part of
this contest they had written a review
before the contest but I liked the
review so much i'm going to give you a
t-shirt Pope Tom pulp tom is a halt
fiction and Buffalo Tom Pope Tom he says
what a great podcast with an insightful
look into the world of comedy and all
that comes with it Marie is such a great
interviewer why is he not a household
name come on people let's make Marie
famous that's two t-shirts called time
that's two t-shirts let's throw it in
from Michael cot yeah oh you know what
Michael cattle probably come up and see
me in San Francisco cuz he lives up
there so Michael [ __ ] come on give you
your t-shirt if he probably probably has
one he's been listening for a long time
but if not Michael I'm happy to give you
one and you can buy me drinks while
we're up there oh we got loaded Michael
cat and i got he came to the show i did
with your for your family oh oh was he
the heckler no no you should i say for
my family because it was all-russian it
was there and guess what that's the last
time I performed in San Francisco really
I was so angry those sets nothing that
you did Oh your family came to see you
well I grew up in San Francisco and so
Soviets are very nosy sure and so if you
found out that you do a show we come
soon that's not nosy the selective no
let me tell you what happened uh we very
much like to laugh and the bed joyful
people there a joyful I was trying to
record a CD so my husband came up with
equipment he put Mike's around the room
we you know we spent money on renting
the room you know we do all the stuff
you do the press Eva things we sold out
thankfully I had big crowds but they
were all Russians all of them and so
they just SAT there and you know no
smoking anymore it's illegal others died
yeah cigarette little bit and they're
talking and they're drunk and they're
the people right next to the microphones
are chatting the whole time really got
their phones out so you had to go back
and listen to it it was awful oh it was
so bad I opened that show oh you did
yeah wait cuz he was up in
the city for sketchfest house every
scholar wanna yeah just open what they
think you how did you go didn't like the
mer why does he have braces on teeth I
do not like do not trust and embraces
surprising though the MC who is and this
is I'm not saying this at all negative a
flaming homosexual yes killed he's a
sweetheart he's a local he did all you
know and he's very funny so oh yeah I'm
not your mate but he's talking about how
you know the the N Judah bus is late
okay someone's like you're right it is
late although all right you know he's
like have a bar Cadair on my agree with
the Queen man oh that is true it is so
it's funny cause it's true so I haven't
been up to any I've been up to satchel
school obviously to him back to visit
but I have not performed in the city
since then I'm still traumatized I
couldn't use any of it I didn't oh mama
that's a bummer yeah but you sweeten it
or is it just cuz you were talked over
there talking Oh mom like do people were
all spies just 30 years ago you don't
have a [ __ ] whisper keep it a secret
and they would yeah I remember I
remember a conversation going on but
between a table yeah after where the
woman got up and walked around to the
other side of the table and been over
yeah and was talking to the person oh
yeah in the middle of the show um why
don't of you I have a travel podcast
that I do so I go all over the world in
the last 10-15 years the Russians and
the Chinese are starting to travel a lot
and they're getting around and in no
matter what the Russians are hilarious
because like I've had more than one tour
guide or like hotel people or whatever
it was and in whatever country tell me
like the typical Russian thing is you
could tell them a million times not to
do something like in Russian yeah
because usually travel in big groups
because they don't speak anything else
so like the Chinese as well they just
don't speak any other language so they
travel in big giant groups they go to
warm beaches they sit they take up all
the the beach chairs they smoke and
drink all day so you see mile throughout
Asia like in via
naw man in Thailand and MIT and but
their typical thing is you could tell
them a million times don't do the look
you can't go past this rope here because
you know for nature you can't and
they'll say yes yes they'll not you know
tell them milky and they'll say yes in
the minute you turn your back they'll
just do this that's how you doing rules
though if you can get away with it then
it yeah that's what each other many
times scuba diving don't touch the coral
it's living to do and minute you turn
your back this plenty of coral oh my god
Jesus man but that's like the typical
you cut up some slack because it's like
new money they have these are people
that haven't traveled much but you're
hoping the next generation Kevin that's
it you know them flicking cigarettes
into the ocean Rita dude dude there's a
there's a Facebook article floating
around right now about why Russians
don't smile and it's so true yeah I
didn't think about no but smiling to
them is is you're nuts or there you're
trying to get something out of that I
belies you smiling at me like if you're
standing at a hotel reception desk right
and I got to check in right I walk up to
your night and I smile immediately like
hi I'm gonna check in my last name is
this in this and when and if you do that
in Russia there like what the [ __ ] is
your problem geez in a place where you
expect the people to hospitality
industry sure there's no hospitality
that's a great story in the there was
some big famous hotel in st. Petersburg
that you know now more people are
traveling there and it's his famous
hotel where world leaders would stay and
everything but they had to send a
consultant in there to tell them to
smile you know that you're gonna handle
an international crowd now you have to
end their like wide well you're doing
our job but yes but there's more to it
and I find that all throughout like
former Soviet bloc countries just like
it's a long switch from this is what we
got take it and shut up right to hi how
may I help you today so customer service
really hasn't come around yet you'll
find that in the Czech Republic and
hungry in a bit and places like that
important they're coming around
important question the Scorpions German
or Russian German alright nevermind hold
on Berta's wire send me your email
address if you haven't and everybody
else
now your home address hit me up
congratulations where I like to think
we're all winners in the row stories
podcast but you guys aren't getting [ __ ]
November today oh and also another quick
this is to thank ice invited you guys
over on a late sunday saturday evening
ruined your saturday night just to talk
to my listeners and not you sorry about
that but uh thank you to Daryl Asher and
his lovely wife Jen Jennifer Asher's
they made me uh Daryl gave me a sampling
of brew from Montana look he'll hook you
up to give the moose moose moose drool
yeah yeah spit it was something like
that lose em from that's from other
listeners a beer over there I've got a
ton of beer from podcast listeners thank
you very much from Tim uh the the
brothers have been the brothers well
yeah yeah no walkie yeah yeah they even
saw me in Chicago when I was playing a
nice very cool took the train down
really from on a Tuesday have they seen
your set no I didn't say they would do
it twice ah anyway Jennifer Azure made a
lure Jenna sure made a lovely coffee mug
for me it has the cover of my album on
it it has a punch line of one of my
jokes on it and I drink coffee out of it
every morning thank you jen i love
getting stuff from listeners step it up
Roberta's wire I know just don't make it
blue that's it that's all the giveaways
we got today I think I think we're it
was a landing thank you guys for thank
you does it be here oh it's good to see
you guys meet a time validate archive oh
and by the way um uh if you're double XL
uh baby yeah you are huh damn right Oh
me make a quick email because I only
have one of those and i only have an XL
so i have a bunch of larges and mediums
so hopefully i have fit listeners okay
where are we at and if you're a double
XL let's is kind of let's put it
together huh you have a salad I mean
don't don't don't dis my listeners man
what this man is a sweet woman I Roberta
a great personality
oh you know that I'm alright so here we
are a little while ago I asked if there
were any questions you had for comedians
and I got a ton of emails with questions
on him so I thought we did round one of
those with one Graham Elwood I think we
all know right I think we all know uh he
answered those very unfunny not a funny
way and so I thought we would tackle the
rest of these uh questions tonight on
the road stories podcast so as I scroll
down my facebook page and look them up
which I should have done before while
you guys were late maybe um not much
yourself oh I know why I want to get you
on here mike siegel um mike siegel cuz i
wasn't even doing stand-up a little over
20 years so over 20 years how many
cruises have you done I've only started
doing them i've done four weeks how many
cruises have you done for four okay and
when did you do those over the holidays
yeah you ruined my joke jerk uh how was
a joke I don't know whose comment up it
was coming what did you want me as well
now it was too late now you run the joke
ask me how many cruises I having crews
have you done 300 yeah which where's the
Joe wouldn't I would happen straight I
would have done the straight guy I
didn't know there was a joke who's there
is it with him it's who's on first oh I
did you run every one of them alright
everyone I was the joke I know i was
just gonna anyway I want to talk to you
about your chips and how they looked and
how were they awful person I jumped ship
and got off early oh oh well now well I
got there was thanksgiving week and i
met the ship on monday before
thanksgiving i found out i was gonna be
going up tuesday night and then I was
done for the whole week and I'm supposed
to stay on the ship till Sunday back
till I got back to Miami and my whole
family was down most of my family lives
in Central Florida outside of orlando
and they said if i'm done tuesday can I
leave and they're like well we're not
paying for it but you can leave and then
I was looking like when on the ship
schedule we were gonna land and st.
Kitts on Wednesday and then we're going
to be at sea on Thursday
a women to it so I got off the ship on
wednes i beliee looked on the internet
and found a flight actually catching
some miles to go back to florida and met
my family Wow for night before
Thanksgiving Senate the rest of the week
there and they just drove bound in Miami
got my flight and I'll really work out
great why can't they just do that as
like I know what happens is like they
book you for the week and you don't
really know the schedule until you get
there and the cruise director tells you
the schedule so this last one I did I
got there again and there was two of us
there's two comics we met the ship on a
Sunday who's the other comic jit gym and
Jay Lamont who all the Lamont brothers
yeah of the Lamont brother the lemond
shame and Jay Lamont yeah Jojo that's
one person isn't Ian run DMC was its jam
and Jay he lives here in LA I didn't
know the man nice fella yeah but so he
met the ship on a Sunday and we got to
go till the next Sunday and we didn't
know they just flew us in and out of
Miami so I'm Sunday to Sunday so he did
like the first two nights and then he
was on the ship for five days doing
nothing I was on the ships of five days
before i even went up oh really why o.o
so he did the first two shows basically
do one main show one gonna get one night
we do you 40 40 to 45 minutes you and
jamie j or just no just his night okay
and so he went up he did a welcome show
in the first night with like 20 minutes
and then you do your main night what
you're doing an early show in the late
show which are 45 each different that's
a dif different set of 20 to 45 do I'd
is 20 and then a 45-45 can be the same
now all right okay okay yeah so there's
really setting in the late so my fear
with doing cruises is I don't think I
have enough clean material yes he has to
be clean not not so much anymore on all
cruises it depends on the line yeah yeah
like carnival I know has like an actual
club where there be like three comics
and you do like club every night that's
great that could be fun I also did a
late show 11 week and they said you
could say anything you want I was like
you're telling me this
sucks sure it was like an eleven o'clock
show and then they warned everybody's
like this is going to be as long as they
tell people and the cruise director is
cool that's it yeah it's all up to the
cruise director but it's certain lines
are old like I guess holland America's
must be really old yeah and I'm doing
one in June in Europe which I'm excited
about oh we're ah that's I meet the ship
in Bordeaux France and we go around a
Normandy coast up through the English
Channel to London and then to Amsterdam
oh so now you stop by and see me in
Bahrain all right I don't know much
about geography it's not close at all
absolutely different continent but
thanks to they make a left in Djibouti
okay yeah but that one is a crystal
which is a higher end 10 secret art is
that very old oh wow so it'll be old
Brits post oh so this could be a child
they're known for their sense of humors
I don't mind that there says a David
cassettes of humor but old bricks old
rich Brits old anyone is tough yeah and
so a squeaky and the references have to
fly oh it go slow I mean the first ship
I did it was like it was this there's on
celebrity mmm but there was a 22 oxygen
with oxygen really take oh yeah oh I've
seen those yeah yeah and that's you know
I know what to expect but but this the
downtime like you with kids and you guys
mean you're there on the whole week yeah
and what do you do you know you work out
for an hour and a half and then yeah and
then you see him everywhere I'm glad
that that week I just did that I was at
the end of the week cuz I could walk
around anonymously all week oh yeah
total him and Jay had to go up first and
for the rest of the week he's walking
hey you're the guy from them what they
hated it usually don't say anything yeah
but at least there that's what you know
we can see their bomb and then you get
left alone haha that's the way to do
well I've done that it's not as good as
it sounds I always wear a hat oh yeah
but the hat down works yeah oh weird
eyes almost where was I was in Palm
Springs at the improv in Palm Springs a
few weeks ago and ice like friday night
after the show i downed about six or
seven single-malt scotches well sure and
slept till three in the afternoon and
rolled out of bed just all stinky
in smelly and put on my sweaty smelly
jus is it right now yes over time but on
my sweaty smelly gym clothes went to the
elevator go gym getting the elevator the
elevator spac and i roll in and I
Jazeera oh yeah good show last night and
I'm just like breath and smell it just
smelly clothes away oh yeah just woke up
I could go to the gym I got off on the
next floor gotta do a different elevator
coming down stairs / cruise the morning
after my show I go into the buffet and
I'm standing here lacking some old lady
just sold southern ladies behind me in
chi and and she's kind of looking at me
and she's next to me in the thing and
she's you wants to say something I tell
but I'm just not I'm didn't say anything
and then she just goes I do believe I
saw you on stage last night oh and i was
at yes that was me fainted no yeah that
was me thanks for coming to the show and
she goes good luck to you in the future
and there's water and I was like well
that's not really a compliment oh say
that's a sad old lady that's a sweet
nice old lady it's a very southern or
yeah you're southern yeah yeah but
another way they can that's like almost
saying bless your heart yeah well ever
insulting you dad you know what bless
yard that's just like her saying could
you look like you're having fun up there
oh here's the thing the worst thing the
worst compliment ever here's the thing
comedy fans and people who are gonna
talk to a comedian after the show the
only thing you ever ever ever have to
say Rachel median is your funny ya don't
fancy it up don't worry this jokes don't
give us jokes don't tell us how much you
liked our shirt even though you liked
our shirt I'll be one of here is you
were funny don't pitch us jokes oh yeah
yeah you can why do people still you can
use this one my attorney just pitched me
a bit yesterday we're on the phone he
goes up here's a good one no you work in
show biz how do you not know that's not
ever appropriate here's what bothers me
and I know this is a pointless point of
view on my end but here's what it ache
as an insult you know bill and copying
he should be a comedian
yeah he is fine he should be assured
yeah should he be a comedian is he gonna
do is kind it just like oh really you
can just become a comedian because
somebody suggest you become a comedian
despite the 20 years what do we have six
players in in stage time in this room
that's one of the reasons that never
tell nobody knows us comedy will never
get the respect to say like a musician
because even if like jazz isn't my thing
I see a guy up there playing I don't say
he's talentless right just not my thing
sure but you see a comedian maybe his
style or her style isn't your thing but
does that mean they're talentless right
now that guy's people oh yeah he's this
guy's you know and and plus i know i
can't play guitar right everybody thinks
they're funny and everybody can make
their friends laugh every I've said they
think that you know even if they have
the best time they'll walk out and go
well that guy was just talking Joe down
to the factories he's just funny he
talks yes well he could be up there no
Joe couldn't no that's the other thing
everybody thinks they have a sense of
humor everybody I told that to I told
that to an executive producer and then I
was not asked back just a chance Wow who
writes for you oh that's interesting
yeah well it's kind of an old zombie
chick no no this any then he followed up
with while your husband is ok with you
just traveling on your own and then
recently I did a gig I was headlining
and then the to the MCA feature were two
dudes and we're all sitting around in
the guy that you know booked the show
whatever was at a country club he looked
at me and goes you get nervous and I
said no no I'm waiting for him to ask
the dudes or really never asked the dude
really just me huh cuz I have titties
right and big ones to kenosha no they're
ok they're just normal they're just
girls oh there's run-of-the-mill yeah oh
yeah yeah all right good Jesus sideways
to get in my know
all right let's Clemmie jus she did a
good luck to you in the future you're
not allowed to come through the front
door here I just had a lovely little
daughter about six months ago lovely
little john's lovely yeah she's a girl
she showed a picture to my mom today she
said it beautifully my daughter you've
sent me pictures of your daughter oh and
that's why i was commenting on her boobs
cuz she's nursing you don't need it Greg
you guys had already forgot I said that
night to bring it back up again to make
it awkward again we're answering
questions question question for crying
out loud question number one how big or
cares boobs what normal a normal hell
exhales normal human all right I don't
know where we left off uh started yeah I
don't know who this we is is is so
random guys I'm so sorry today I'm a
little Spacey I've been dealing with my
mom's in town i'ma deal with my mom your
mom is a lovely Lea my mom's lovely lady
my mom is you would never believe she's
75 years old no no really yes she does
not look so he does not look 75 and she
is got the hearing of a hundred and four
year old dead person and my wife who's
also 75 ah looks great looks great fancy
great she also had a virus which killed
eighty percent of the hearing in her
left ear years ago so she's partially
can't hear and then my four-year-old
won't listen to me so it's just me
repeating myself day like on and it's
driving me [ __ ] nuts so bear with me
a little scattered and I lash out at you
for no apparent reason ways Mary's
hearing is that permanent yeah yeah she
got yeah she was doing you agonize I
think the listen I've listeners hear
about this once a year when I complain
about my relatives being in town dad she
was doing yoga and she got really dizzy
and you know kept getting dizzy and had
go get MRIs and you know how like most
doctors like listen we don't wanna we
wanna make any suggestions on what it
might be you don't wanna you know we
don't want to go large scare you don't
want to alarm you we don't know what it
is not this one is like well we're
looking for tumors it could be cancer be
probably like
three weeks it was we thought she had a
brain tumor but it turned out was just a
weird virus that attacked a nerve in her
ear so she can't really hear that well
oh so but it's really more about me
right now in the campaign I'm going
through having to talk to three deaf
people alright question from a year
frozen off yesterday by the
dermatologist what so there you go right
there where did you have a little sun
damage oh yeah he took out a little like
I guess is looking nitrogen or something
yes and they just ya know what and one
of the reasons it's like on this side on
the left side driving son is banging it
you know i was under the other sunscreen
folks that's all I'm saying everybody's
free to wear sunscreen yeah um i was at
baz lurman yep I remember film director
I got the reference the only film
director with a top ten hit look it up I
was under the impression that glass in
the window cut out the UV rays probably
does but not when you ride with the
window open it's probably not a good
yeah we don't sell you're also thinking
I am half an idiot but wouldn't you also
think like the glass kind of like when
you try to murder ants yeah um with a
glass and almost I feel like my cuz I am
I even with the window up it's burning
like I can feel the side of my face
burning as I sit in traffic on the 405
with it's not the heat that gets you
from the Sun it's the UV rays right but
I don't know I just feel like it almost
magnifies it if you have a magnifying
glass for a window yes look oh you got
your the size of that head in that comes
will Ted loud used to do that Joe
there's like an AMC Pacer joke back with
AMC Pacer zzzz like you want to replace
the glass with magnifying glass just
look what I pull you over I just want to
see if your head was that goddamn big
that's like they should come up with a
bifocal um friend would yield yeah huh
why not right you're like what's over
there wait what does that sign say what
is that wait what is that as a street no
they have trifocals now answer trifocals
i believe oh my god this kind of
quadrants [ __ ] yeah I different places
you're like Abby's I look if like 40
little squares okay quite this is the
road space pod cast net thrust you have
a ramble and here's what we should
everybody podcast is we never get to the
judges everybody is going back into the
leading all the reviews right now except
for Roberto's wire she's a lovely woman
of god bless her all right ah now I did
the first half of these with grandma
would like I said so I don't remember
where we left off so a lot of oh oh
alright like what you think only gonna
get through one is just kidding Josette
a cook hey just okay Josette uh what
what makes you think you're funny Wow
Kyra that woman what makes you what
makes you think you're running [ __ ] know
your place what makes you figure um I
mean obviously I childhood trauma I you
can read that many different ways yeah
but I don't think it's it's a listener
so they're not being font did she use Oh
comics at all caps is something Ariel
boring for ? soap afterwards and did she
do that but I go into ? in the beginning
the outside da one ya like what is an
axial what makes you think you're funny
what I never heard the brig unda that
good there's a question I hadn't oh yeah
they have a bad side down question it's
called you think you're funny all right
back then son back down sharing maybe
she an accent even in that question oh
no no just uh what makes you think
you're funny I mean I was beaten so yeah
Michael my moms with me this week I'm
beaten again so I should be really funny
come June what kind of getting back to
what we were talking bout earlier how
everybody kind of fix their funny yeah
everybody can make their friends laugh
but I like things in school where I
wasn't the class clown but i knew i
could make different groups laughs
uh-huh like you can make when you can
make like the Nerds laughs and then you
can make like the stoners laughter every
so often the teacher yeah yeah laughs
and you're like okay maybe I'm seeing
things in a weird maybe I'm different
than everyone else do you remember the
first
time you got a big laugh like just in
life not in general not on stage but
just in life here shaking heard yes yes
what was it I remember mine uh i think
it was like I had some with the Soviets
because they like to drink okay and so
it was easy to make them laugh when I
was a kid but my first um real like kind
of unexpected set that I did Oh was in
the fourth grade mm-hmm my teacher was
mrs. Gail hmm and she was frightening
really scary and she had speaking of
quad vocals she had these glasses these
really thick coke bottle oh sure yeah it
made her eyes a gigantic yes darkness
and so um I did an impression of her in
front of the class Oh with her watching
with her watching right um would you put
on your face but like I junko cautious
okay I turned around and I just like put
like my hands up like big huge owl eyes
and I said whatever her little
catchphrase was which was always
something like shut up Kyra yeah it was
usually the carib i was i was in every
single principal's office in every
school i attend every single one he
socializes a lot in his chance yeah
attention if she was [ __ ] [ __ ] up she
spent more time on her studies but i'm
not making people laugh you know the
whole class erupted and so did mrs. gail
and so did like our teachers oh okay and
i think there was like a parent
volunteers oh we're like three adults
and they all I think it was like a
tension you know like you know when you
break the tension in a comedy club as
well like people like if there's a
heckler sure you somehow can come back
or if you dig yourself in a hole and
then you come back and was like ah yeah
yeah thank you Oh in your openers tank
and you come out and Soviets are
flicking cigarettes at them um good luck
to you in the future yeah but I I made
everyone laugh and I that it was it was
immediately in that moment where I was
like oh this
awesome but I mean like in the first
grade I was already cracking jokes I
don't do the story a million times I
feel like I've said on your podcast I
had a desk on the outside of the
classroom in the hallway you never told
me that oh yeah data let you were like
letterman out there you had your own
desk put a panel she don't like a little
couch w 8 the pace today huh so Mike is
that like hall monitor I know we have a
clip we have a clip of you eating the
paste I would sit and write jokes right
so I wrote a joke i'm in the classroom
and and he was at it was that this was a
Hebrew Academy so it was like a
religious school so they're asking
something about Moses right and I was
like before we get to Moses can I ask
everybody or a question I swear I job
this is hilarious why is it called the
restroom I mean is anyone really
arresting in there ah cuz are you taking
a nap in the restroom get out rabbi
Lipner sent me out into the hallway at
my little desk i SAT there writing jokes
really the door a few minutes later key
are you ready to join the class ready to
come back and join the class I would do
whatever bit I made up in that moment in
the class the laughter just covered my
body with Hani it was just like right
the sound of their laughs that was it
and then he'd slammed the door my face
like I guess you're not ready slam and I
was just celebrating in the hallway
hilarious ice cream ever told me that
story okay well that's yeah the first
comedy bit i hold on the first laughs i
remember getting was sixth grade
christian school mmm in school and I was
telling a story and I remember and I
said I seen this dog the other day and
the teacher said I saw this dog and I
said you saw him too and just right yeah
yeah yeah but the first bit I ever wrote
bits and we had ice do you guys have ice
in school suspension what's ice in
school suspension oh yeah yeah yeah so
you instead of going to classes you'd go
to one room all day basically the
breakfast club all day yeah for three
days yeah oh my
passion you got all your work yeah and
you can do all your working like the
first hour and then you just had three
days to [ __ ] off in this room and so I
would sit there and I would write bits
and then wow it's my first time I wrote
[ __ ] what about you remember did we
talk here from now I remember like in
sixth grade I had to do a speech we had
to do a presentation it was on
presidents mmm something that I ended up
doing like impressions of presidents
like that I don't yeah it was like a
weird I think you know I probably stole
stuff that I saw and what would even
Abraham Lincoln sound like I would say
something like something like this and
then with george washington and i would
like played that I had like wooden teeth
right like I don't remember what it was
haha but we did in the homeroom and it
killed killed and then they asked me to
do it in front of the entire class real
oh and then when I did in front of the
entire class I kind of like it went okay
right i forgot i fumbled a couple lines
and the pressure was really on because
they'd built it up like oh he does this
cute thing and did you know maybe show
started late the light yeah remote as
well crowd they tapered the room yeah
drop the checks on me my friend I know
I've told the story on on the show
before my first state like quote unquote
stand-up set was that a talent show at
my church youth group and I did uh I did
the unknown comedian over the bag he had
no comic and my the only joke i
remembers i had my bag on my head and
then I had a plastic bag over it I said
hey I'm the unknown comic you probably
don't recognize because I just had
plastic surgery oh is that a plastic bad
i got you killed killed I don't need
your Georgia oh they love me I will see
I went dark with her I was like this how
I commit suicide you put a plastic bag
over the paper babies wow wow let's see
i gargles dark how would George
Washington say
well you know you have the dental work
um so Josette suck it we didn't like
your question no Josie it's a nice nice
it was a great question just just very
vague ah makes you a human yeah yeah
funny the next question comes from
gathering mar bet actually no this girl
i worked what you do have people in
djibouti yeah I cheese actually I worked
with her at a restaurant here in town
years ago no that's interesting yeah hmm
do you think you're funny hey what the
what alfani do you think you are and
secretly deem the audience idiots if
they don't laugh are there oh how many
questions are you going to write
gathering are there non humorous energy
rooms that are impossible to turn around
if you can turn them around how do you
do it is it a who and to hold them know
when to walk away no one to run kind of
thing is your second language comedians
in general our morose individuals how
long who long to die unless they're on
stage or on set when I she was writing
an entire essay holy crap am I the first
person to ask you a question gathering a
lot of words you're the only human I've
ever talked to when it comes to your act
just how far down the road of
irreverence are you willing to travel I
feel like we're on a first date with
gathering sat down let's just have an
appetizer possible to swipe right unless
my even is that even right I don't know
that's a tiger thing isn't it yeah is
that tender that you tender no angel
what do you do I've never done the never
done the e online now no just get tail
thrown at you like a mud fight yeah a
mud fight okay put the mud fight is that
is from hell yeah yeah never the action
is the mud fight it's a romantic
southern saying mm-hmm right let's break
down this all right just pick your
favorite pick one out of gatherings I
like you but the other rooms that just
suck at yeah someone's have a bad vibe
yeah sure in them yes this one
uh goes in the hallway well how do they
how do they start they suck well I mean
it will you tell people it's just hard
to get a when you describe a bad room to
people it's usually like a high ceiling
yeah I have the people are far away any
t stay care just like you right and it's
not conducive there's some things that
are just not conducive to come if it's
outdoors if it's daylight hours if it's
a what a lot of times it's like it
energy kind of thing and if it's just
too if the people are to spread apart
they can't get it just the vibe in there
energy energy with whether it be
positive or negative is contagious and
yeah in order to catch that's why
there's a laugh track and yeah in order
to catch something you have to be close
to the person so that's why you don't
spread out an audience you put them all
together right you know have you done
the new Stanford and Sons mm-hmm jersey
city yeah got him in there today hey
they have a new location um this is the
third location I've done with them have
been you know I did the Westport one
years that was years ago there she went
out to Overland Park yep Oh Alan side
imagines now they're back in overland
park and they're in a room where um I
believe people have been murdered ah
yeah has and I feel bad if anyone's
listening or Greg Greg glaciers
listening if anybody's not murder I'm
sorry but that's just the truth and it
just you walk in and maybe cuz I'm a
Russian gypsy I immediately sensed like
there's a bad vibe in here they're
really just negative bad energy I was
about that about the comedy store yeah i
agree there is who's it uses a Patton
Oswalt used to say they used to feels
like there should be arms coming out of
the wall like there really is yeah black
walls kind of like people died in here
you just walk in your people some
somebody something died in here
definitely one percent I will say this
and I've said it a hundred times I saw a
ghost at the company store yeah yeah me
too and I think it was Sam I think was
gonna send to be honest really Ireson
honest with you and I'm not a big not
Carol rock care
Karen run tau C or anything actively
seeking ghosts and stuff but I saw and
where were you upstairs in the belly
room that's right yep really me too the
upstairs room there's an upstairs room
at the comedy store and you can walk in
from the outside up a flight of stairs
and I was walking in during the daylight
and I saw a big shadow very hulking kind
of shadow with a long coat come down the
back stairs and go out the door wait so
you were inside I was walking in from
the outside you know I can go out there
stairs outside and go into it past the
stage yeah I was walking into there and
he walked down the stairs on the other
side and out the back out the front door
wow so I used to do every sunday night
at the belly room I'm sorry met you yeah
yes I used to get there first i'll set
up now i don't know if they've changed
the light switches while they're across
the entire room so you had to go up the
back steps in the dark and this is
before i had a flip phone so there's
like no you know flashlight on your
phone which yeah i would be totally fine
but i had to go on my hands and knees
because i felt like if i walked upright
i was in danger and I was kind of like
feel my way its pitch black cuz we're
crawling on your hands and knees in the
comedy club because there are no windows
in the belly we're sure if the lights
are out UPS block and it's just pitch
black and you have to go and define like
it's a touch along the walls and one
time I forgot to kind of hunched you
know crunch down hunched down what's the
word I'm looking for and I was just
standing walking up and I got pushed
down two three four little steps from
that little mezzanine yeah yeah yeah I
was pushed that's where I guess I'm
talking about he can't down the stairs
and went out that let's talk about the
same tires bowl on and I spoke to
whatever the [ __ ] that was and I go look
I'm here every Sunday you know me don't
[ __ ] around I'm really pissed right now
and I left and I didn't come back and
tell like Peter sprite and dad oh
there's that's how you get your back
this guy's for footage we can speak to
them he's one of their own um you know
Aron Kader and all people that were you
know doing the sunday show with me I was
like I'm not going up there until
someone comes with me Wow and that was
the last time though I was messed with
Wow yeah I wonder if it's the same good
cuz it's exactly where you got pushed is
exactly where i saw the guy certain
people that are like that's [ __ ] you
lost your footing you and you know i get
people are skeptical cuz yeah I get it
but I'm just relaying what happened to
me too that's what I'm saying I saw
something yeah that's what I'm saying I
don't you know but that said the belly
room is a pretty kick-ass room so I
don't think that room is an energy
sucker I didn't push me I'm not a [ __ ]
but I saw something that's all I'm
saying but that's not no that's not it
no it's not a energy do the original
room can be an energy sucker yeah
sometimes but I'm telling you right now
if you go to Kansas you like yellow
right finish that sergeant that's it was
the end you don't like you feel I did
not enjoy my week there yeah it was just
every night felt like a heaviness uh-huh
like a real like stress anxiety in the
room I didn't feel anxious but it was
bizarre you can also not a good room you
can also it's also dependent on the
crowd too and i can tell you can you I
can tell well I can tell I can tell
what's gonna be an easy show and what's
gonna be a little bit of a work when the
announcer goes are you guys ready to
have a good time and they're like yeah
you're like okay that's a good crowd but
when they go are you ready to have a
good time yeah come on you can do better
than that it's Saturday night or by the
way no crowd has ever been ready to have
a good time on the first time the first
question you're always asked two times
but I used to say and I told Todd
Glass's when he was on there do you The
Improv used to have a video of Todd
glass yeah I love those explaining the
rules and you know the only way Todd
glass can can do it and I knew it was
gonna be an easy night when that video
got lots of laughs and not that it
wasn't funny like I would judge the
laugh right or from that that means cuz
they're focused they're watching you're
attentive they're there to have a good
time but if they're just not paying
attention and rifling that week that i
was in Kansas two guys got up because um
they asked me they interrupted my show
and asked me hey so are we allowed to
talk oh I said well you know what first
of all thank you so much for asking
haha granted you interrupted me in the
middle of a setup but I'm glad that you
bring this up no so shed it Wow in a
playful way you know I was still playful
but I kind of I have to you know kind of
set the boundaries sure sure they got up
and left they were so pissed that they
weren't allowed to talk well far you
know great that they let me know in 2016
do you not know that you're not allowed
to talk how are we so new to comedy
still it's like way cooler more did you
ever did you see this thing of whether
there was a play and some guy in New
York like plugs in his phone in yeah a
win on stage a bug in his phone yeah
yeah yeah I mean how do you not know how
do you not know people are morons no
parts but keep listening folks come out
to the show's yeah we love love
everybody we wouldn't be there for us
and for you yeah morons haha good energy
gathering stay I know you can't talk and
gathering stay home with your 19 yeah no
kidding a short question and these do
you think you're funny another do you
think you're funny it's not funny do you
think you are no still gathering I'm
going over her do you secretly deem the
audience idiots no morons yeah uh if
they don't laugh oh that's interesting
do you think do you blame them if they
don't laugh it depends yeah sometimes
okay if they're douches and they have
been consistently douchey from the
beginning to the end sure yes okay yes
well but if it's a joke that usually
kills you don't get a laugh but you're
doing fine the rest of the set then it's
like oh maybe I didn't commit to that or
right I started it weird or no I I I had
a guy a guy interrupted me a couple
weeks ago at the irvine improv and then
I did my next joke and it didn't get a
laugh as big a laugh because he [ __ ]
killed the whole vibe right he killed
the whole so I blame him for killing it
cuz now that now people are checked out
and I'm getting them back into the
groove of things I think people forget
that we are not a television show yeah
and we are dependent on it
is a symbiosis like its symbiotic
symbiotic relationship right and we are
not just robots so if something like
that does happen it can mess with you
and it can throw you off or if your
professional you just still kill so
thank you for playing at me on that one
oh here's a new years the thing that
noticing exhibition me on um all right
so sure yes it might be enjoyable for
the listeners dacia a heckler gets
slammed down and shut down but [ __ ] you
know heckler cycling is not good stop
promoting it stop comedians stop posting
you shutting down a heckler on stage I I
see it all the time on a tackler last
night I shut them down and everybody
laughs so now people think oh that's
part of the show it's not part of the
show we work hard to do this yeah we
have something we're presenting to you
we don't need it though if the Chicago I
was either to Tribune or the sun-times
did a whole article on hecklers a few
years ago well what was their angle
Frankel was we love a good beckler
getting shut down and getting one
[ __ ] chick I forget it was all the
only reason she was writing articles
such good name drops a Calvin a kiss
every five minutes but oh man I gotta
look at that article pissed me off so
bad man can I tell you what I do they're
like oh it says if it tells us if you're
a good comedian if you can handle the
heckler no no you don't know idiot last
time I was at the store Comedy Store and
uh got pushed down the stairs haha I was
in the main room just just being an
audience member just hanging out and I
just poked my head in and Oh Maron was
on stage so I just kind of stood the
battery left right back to the next time
I came on I stood in the back and there
were these two dudes who I think in
their heart of hearts are comedy fans
who and they are probably there from
Marin I'm gonna assume okay but they
were the ones that yell their delight
instead of laughing at a joke could we
have an exam I'm gonna give you an
example so mark has a joke is like
what's up with trader joes and the guy
goes
yeah so he's enjoying himself but
instead of just laughing or applauding
like don't you agree trader joes is
weird or whatever he's just going whoa
and he was doing this the entire set but
he was all the way in the back and I
guess mark just kind of tuned him out or
sure he did actually address it once um
but he didn't slam him down or anything
but he did it he's I was with another
comic and we look at each other like
that is so annoying yes laughs you're
enjoying yourself if you don't know how
to laugh just smile okay you knows
enough people here to me your lack of
laughter so this is what happened um
he's right next to the hallway with that
little like sneaker d call we get to
them backstage yeah and no no no no
where you can go to a kind of Allah
dress out to the kitchen okay the bar
he's sitting right there next to the
door and these two comics walk out but
they stopped and they're discussing
something and he yells shut the [ __ ] up
the audience guy yeah oh it's like dude
you have been so disruptive haha this
entire the internet time I've been in
this room you've not you've just been
absolutely the worst yeah and grant
these two comics they should have taken
it outside I stopped for a minute to
like discuss Lina something and they
were whispering this guy was like so he
just wrapped to the show to say shut the
[ __ ] up it's like how do you not get it
so hard how are you so not in the loop
with just common sense I bet reminds me
of when I went to see you too and
everybody's phone was up recording the
show and I'd tell the guy in front of me
hey dude I didn't pay all this money to
stare at your arm you got to put that
down or to stare at the concert through
your phone yeah yeah and so he was like
oh I'm sorry was very apologetic but
everybody a guy recorded the whole show
on his phone switched phones for the
other battery recorded and then had the
nerve to me come up and my wife was
made this show he's like hey man he gets
me is Yancy's phone when you take a
picture of me and my wife in front of
the stage I'm like no I looked at that
phone the whole [ __ ] concert i'll
have to look at it now and i would said
no i was so pissed sorry people's hot
I'm tell you they forget people are
forgetting what it's like just to be in
a live event yeah yeah I'd be in the
moment it just be present just didn't
enjoy the concert be aware of the people
around you yeah oh this place seats
30,000 yet I'm the only person here okay
I'll just yeah hold up my phone this
isn't right we're all good nobody minds
this that's what I told you about the
Chrissie Hynde was the best of that I
always had a just he had signs
everywhere they're like we asked no
phones and this and then she went out
first song she's playing she sang one
saw some guy in the front row said turn
it off turn the [ __ ] she's playing
turn off your [ __ ] phone and then he
wouldn't get him out and so with some
guys they took him out good Wow and then
yeah she's just like you know you said
and then she was she would stop playing
if you pulled it out and then at they
like the Encore she said okay you guys
can take out your phones right now I
know you all wanted to Wow get her duh
and then everybody pulls it out and and
then she played a song and halfway
through during they like solo what you
guys look like [ __ ] idiots looking
through those she says she get she went
uh this makes me not want to do it
anymore wow she was over it and I get it
yeah just like what are we here for you
guys are all I will say I mean the good
in clubs are much smaller in concert
venues but clubs are all over phones
being pulled out are they I five notice
I see blue lights on people's faces all
the Amelia and I say dude if you need to
sneak a text I get it I'm a parent I get
it but turn down the light on your phone
oh damn it she's like I'm telling a joke
all of a sudden like I see you know your
face I can lit up blue you're like
staring at it for all I know is you're
just like I'm gonna check facebook right
you don't mean I can hurt like her today
I call me the blue chins
yeah engines out there tonight a good
one new hairs lachance good luck I tell
you really really bad he'll gig with in
in regards to phones sure this I was
part of gatherings question about a
whatever 50 questions questions um this
was our just this past holiday ah for
soldiers down south san diego pendleton
can thank you English is my second who
can't go home for the holidays okay they
put on a comedy show for them right and
they gave them like raffle prizes
everybody won something some guy wanna
bike and and it was a great event for
them right Road stories t-shirt hello
not a blue one and then three comics
were there to entertain them three late
yes what are you doing there first like
a populist like Apocalypse Now like
apocalypse so the first comic goes up
that's bill nobody pays attention nope
ok 0 so faces in phones oh okay have
they there's announcements or the show
is yes they know and now somebody they
know what their it's called like comedy
and laughs preceding this they give it
away stuff and then so the stuffs
happening before you guys giving this
guy won a basket of whatever this guy
wanted okay they were women there too
but mostly dudes and mostly 18 I mean
and very rude very very very rude now
now on top of this terrible sound the
mike kepka right gagging on a [ __ ] no
the mic kept I was gonna say sounded
like your mother yes are you gonna drink
that water so the mic is going out and
it's just all crackly and I go back to
the the audio guy that was there like
please we need another mic and he's like
scrambling to find another one I was way
up last so I'm walking around policing
the room and there's a guy just speaking
wait like wait way too loud and i said
and i rubbed his shoulders i stood
behind him and I rub his shoulders you
know why not just kill with kindness
sure
I said hey sweetie oh I whispered in his
ear ago would you mind keeping it down
because the sound is really bad anyway
and it's really hard for the comic to to
work when you're shouting and he's like
oh sure no problem right so then he
pulls out his phone and everybody there
round tables like a freaking Bar Mitzvah
to the worst yeah everybody at the round
table pulls out their phone too it's a
sea of Facebook and Twitter sure sure
cuz I'm walking around yeah like an
eighth grade teacher checking for
cheaters from table to table and I'm
noticing everyone has their phones out
playing some 7up then the next comic
Jane Murphy goes up sweetheart but I
she's also you know the trouble with the
mic is a terrible Mike and I'm getting
more and more pissed cuz I'm next
nobody's mad because choking on a
[ __ ] they're really they're really
rude right so i am now fired up right oh
you get that Russian blood going that's
it first thing I do I couldn't get up on
stage and I go if I see one [ __ ]
phone on i will put down this microphone
I don't care that I drove an hour and a
half to get here right I won't get paid
and I will be in my car and I will leave
Wow so that is those are my rules now
[ __ ] I was and I go look there
in the military maybe they need a little
like you know drill sergeant choice
everyone was like super like back
straight hands and laps you know and I
start 10 minutes in this guy pulls out
his phone and I said sir I will give you
exactly 1 second to put that away and he
goes nah I'm okay oh and he's in the
front and I said okay so here's what I
have to do now and I put the mic down
and I left the room Wow everybody's like
what the [ __ ] yeah pissed yeah people
are standing up there in his face
they're coming outside looking for me
i'm already I'm leaving Wow and I drove
Jen Murphy by the way
I'm in minor yo gen start the car car
I'm in my car I'm like I'm going yeah
and um these people there i think
they're Marines right so they get up and
they're like if i can put your phone
away what's your [ __ ] problem you
goes I don't have to and they get in a
huge fight what and they kick this guy
out Wow and they come find me and I was
like all right I'll come back Wow I mean
there you have to you have to draw the
lines why are we bothering answering
these questions when you're sitting on
that story yeah that was a guide to
[ __ ] 20 minutes reading gatherings
questions I could have listened to that
one of the worst nights no wow cuz I had
to go to a place that I don't enjoy no
now I understand why do i have to now
dig myself out of that no I that's
seriously doubt my time were you doing I
mean 40 40 yeah I was closing it I'm
about 10 minutes in when this all the
way down yeah you and the parking lot
did that count as part of your time that
reminds me of the time you were hosting
that graduation show of a class remember
the down in at the improv at the improv
mike siegel was hosting Leslie Wolf's
graduation class yes yes and I was
headlining it oh yeah I'm sure you've
had lighted before right she always
brings in a she calls it a celebrity
guest but then hires me I da made I
can't remember I so so they you know
there's like 15 students who do five
minutes they went through their class
and all their friends are there and then
a pro closes it down and there were
these two girls in the front row with
their phones up taking selfies of
themselves remember that and dude I
gotta see Maurice nap through the whole
show the whole show selfie selfies and
smilin and mother friend was up there
was like trying to get a picture of them
to with their friend up there and you
know these condone this is their first
time on stage in front of an audience
they don't know how to handle with it so
they're just rolling through and it was
in I'd like to go the doorman this is
the improv you know we know everybody
there like dude Avery we can you just go
and touch like we said something to him
before and then there in the front row
they can't kick him out and then I talk
to the door and he won't do it and I got
up there and I don't remember what I
talk I was talking about traffic or
something going
come in here and I was like the traffic
so bad everybody's on their phones and
then they started taking a selfie again
and that then I just like and then you
get here in the same person on the phone
is still on the [ __ ] phone in the
front row taking selfies through the
whole goddamn i ripped on these people
first 15 minutes straight man and the
place just exploded they loved it oh
good yeah yeah but I never I don't think
I've ever I haven't been that way since
and I don't think I've ever snapped like
that before on stage did I tell you what
happened after that I was like at the
bar afterward uh-huh like those girls
came said the bar you know their hangers
your hands and they should be what was
that guy's name at the end you know his
name I go yeah I don't know haha you
have his email I can I don't know every
birthday leo oh it wasn't gonna ship you
it with you yeah here's his email here's
his phone number actually Pat Francis
sort of good yeah well then after that
think I was talking to the door guy and
they came up afterwards and they cross
their arm is mean the door guy and they
go we want to know what jokes you would
have done if we weren't here I'm like
what I'm like well we obviously gave you
a material tonight so we want to know
what jokes you would have done if we
weren't here and if you're funny or not
I said well I'm here again on Saturday
night you can pay twenty dollars to come
back and see my set like we want to know
now and the doorman close the door on
them yes nice good times take a selfie
with your set list you guys missed and
i'll email it to him oh you didn't give
me your email address let's do one more
question and then we'll roll out of here
cuz i am hungry ah I gotta get to a gig
you got a gig tonight yeah I am at the
what did I say Oh George oxnard knights
of columbus oh really what it does you
have gigs no you up I'll do Knights of
Columbus any day the way you know does
it tend to be good gigs they can't be
yeah what's two dollar beers haha
there's a moose a royal order of moose
over here I was thinking about starting
to show at yeah you should cuz grand mal
was part of it I think Graham did one
everyone at the Santa Monica one counted
by the Santa Monica College there yeah
that's what I'm talking about an elks or
a moose it's a moose that's what I'm
talking about okay
see him being part of like a skull and
crossbones underground he's already I
could totally see it so you love bonatti
who else is on the show honestly I don't
know ok now just someone booked me and
Paige good go so I gotta get a she's
gonna get on the road yeah Oxnard's up
there yeah all right Jim Earl very funny
comedian Jim Earl uh-uh what Earl and
blanks and banks and what's his jumping
jamming jam and jo geum in lamont Jimmy
Geralyn I'm blanking on their name they
were a comedy duo he wrote what happened
to my career hahaha well you do you went
to work for Jon Stewart at the Daily
Show and he [ __ ] you over we all know
that uh Chris White wrote what came
first [ __ ] are [ __ ] well you're an
[ __ ] Chris uh I don't care if you
don't listen to my show you boys edit
these I don't fiery I didn't read them I
told you haven't read them all I'm ready
as we're going you can edit them as we
go okay I'm could have done a minute of
preparation oh well I was that was the
appeal of this episode if I didn't read
them ahead of time gotcha I was gonna
throw spring the money to say Cox good
okay fine I don't care I don't care uh
Joseph cough longtime listener uh wrote
can you teach a person to be a stand-up
comic great question is a good question
Joseph and Joseph has been listening me
for a very very long time and a hundred
percent appreciate you still being on
board your question saw him a t-shirt
for that question he already has like
four all right kind of fitting Kettleman
off the comedy class oh yeah yeah it is
I think there's things you can teach of
like you know physical things and
basically a lot of it comes down to
editing cut everything yeah you tell
somebody to stand other than that is
just doing it and I think you have an
innate sense of comedy or you don't sure
yeah I think you can teach someone the
same way um you can teach someone how to
play a sport mm-hmm if they already have
a foundation if they're already athletic
mm-hmm they're not all like butter
fingers and yeah you know if they're
already is that what you were you
butters they're all not Marie
just say it you know if they already
have that raw material yes hmm but um my
only problem I don't have a problem with
comedy classes I do not have a problem
with them i think you know look I took
so many workshops when I first got to la
The Groundlings and shares writing in
another writing class and a comedy thing
in it and it is a commercial audition
class like I think they're super super
important my only thing is people that
prey on the people sure you know that's
my oh that's why I get a little sad
where I'm not saying anyone that we know
does this but there are classes where
they prey on these people who have stars
in their eyes and it's like they
encourage them and knowing that they're
not really gonna get far yeah but they
want their class to be a success and so
they like you're doing great you're it
you're you can headline now mm-hmm it's
like oh my god oh yo what are you doing
well I think and I've come around on
this I used to be adamantly against and
up classes but I when I found out the
great one of the greatest comedians ever
Wendy Liebman took one and I thought
maybe I should rethink how comedy
classes are a lot of people have no idea
honestly how to go about it right on
stage for the first time and then you
just go okay like anything you would
take a class and then maybe and then
your graduation is like the one we did
that you know you'll get some time get
to go on the improv a lot of people are
never did it again right sure but they
wanted to try it and you know they had a
night to bring their friends out I think
I think you can learn the structure of
it and it's yeah you to develop as a
comedian right but a lot of again take
it and they realize that you know this
was not for me yeah and so it's good to
know but yeah they can they always had
that thing yeah we I tried it once and
first time on stage bombed yo ya bombed
horrible ha yeah terribly yeah Mike oh
yeah yeah well at that time it was so
late I told the guy was my first time
and then you put me on last and there's
like three other comics there but ya
didn't I don't one thing must have hit
enough that made me come back I'd say I
don't remember if I bombed or did well
but I was so pumped it was a blur and
running that I was so excited to do it
again that I finally did it oh yeah
why'd you do it for so long so i don't
i'm probably tanked
so can I say something really quickly
cuz I just you actually spoke with an
open mic or on the phone a couple days
ago you do though and yeah she asked if
she could ask me for some advice and I
said anytime call me so she called me
and she asked if she should take a
comedy class and I said yes here's why
sometimes you just need to network and
find your class your comedy like your
graduating class like you're a buddy or
someone that you can trust or other
comics that are into it and use it like
that maybe the teacher that's teaching
it is not she in LA yeah okay not gonna
be like your mentor forever yeah yeah
but use it to network use it to meet
other people have a friend to go to an
open mic with right yeah that actually
is more powerful than learning like
always make sure your premise is five
words long whatever their techniques are
that I think is more important is I
having a bunny front line in an accent
yeah yeah kind of stuff that's good but
not every joke is gonna happen right
right but for me finding comedy buddies
that's a meet me at the hostel at
midnight I'm scared it's all Jana and
then you go and you do a set with no
sound of no lights for Germans and you
do well you're like all right let's keep
doing this the greatest thing I think I
got out of that first night was that I
met I went by myself I didn't tell
anybody about it a very scary personal
thing to try it for the first time and
then I got there and I met other guys
and they and I met one guy that night
told me at this time in Chicago there
was a place to get on stage as an open
my gir every night of the week and he
basically wrote out on Mondays you can
go to this place I was easy go to this
place and that was the first night and
then I found is like oh my people right
we can sit and talk about comedy all I
could do that with my other friends
you're sure you know you find your crowd
that if you get anything out of it you
found a crowd and then I found just by
going these people but yeah and then it
here no this is a Chicago Chicago
Chicago many town yeah and uh yeah
there's a social aspect bettiah usually
like in improv classes are that way too
yeah you know these people go through
second city or UCB and they those are
your friends for your whole life it yeah
you know then you do each other's video
you know you act in each other stuff you
write together yeah are you think what
Mike is saying is that he has a comedy
class yeah I sign it right me it's
called chuckle chuckle let's go go it's
called funny Mike's funny class yeah
Mike makes the jokes class no no you
know you say that um about finding
camarada and friends and one thing I've
always been kind of envious of mike and
i think i dont no cure I've curious
shares the same thing a scary got
started out here or San Francisco here
yeah so did I Mike in Pat Francis and
jimmy pardo and Mike Schmidt and chip
chinnery and all those guys go back 20
25 years right they got started in
Chicago yeah so now they have a group of
people out here I got started out here
yeah I have group of people out here but
they're not really everyone's transient
here yeah you know it's art stand up and
they take off yeah yeah so it's really
cool to like stay in your town don't
come out here and start stay in your
town make friends grow together there
and then move out and that Barry was a
good place to suck you know you could
just be bad and then it wasn't a
pressure of like somebody's gonna see
you yeah anywhere definitely but if
somebody made it out of there got a deal
or something we're all there's a very
supportive community we're all happy
like hey put this on the map maybe
they're going back and look for more of
us yeah as opposed when I went to New
York and then here somebody get
somethings like why why did he get it
come on i do a carpet yeah i was in the
same really good Washington bit though
yes ah you're gonna bring that back you
should see is a Lincoln let's get on the
cruise ladies and gentlemen thank you
for listening today uh do three
questions yeah we'll do it again come
back odeon let me tell you why Kieran
Mike have been on here a lot but when I
came to when it came time to answer you
guys questions I ask these two because
you are seriously two of the people that
make me laugh and I love talking to so
thank you guys very much for coming out
and doing this again Mike I know I call
you all the time to fill in and I really
appreciate it I wish I had something
else to do I have nothing so if you guys
don't forget if I announced your name if
you want a t-shirt email me so I can get
your address and your size and i'll send
it out i'll send out some Road story
stickers for you for free and if you
want some Road story stickers I give me
a shout all male amount I do
mail outs on Tuesdays and I have a few
extra t-shirts laying around I'm happy
to let them go at a discount price you
want to hit me up i'll let him go for
fifteen bucks twenty bucks something
like that sound like that you get email
me let me know your size and if you
don't want a t-shirt if you don't want
to buy my CD rusty Cal you can get at
Amazon iTunes marieforleo.com and your
online stores and if you don't want to
make a donation but you wanna just you
know what I've been listening this
podcast for seven years tweet about it
tweet about it once throw it up on the
Facebook once won't kill you it'll help
out the show and uh you might not get
anything free but you'll go to sleep
knowing that you helped somebody else uh
all right that's it guys where can we
find you carousel donavah check here a
comedy you got a special coming out i'm
sorry we didn't get a chance to talk
about it it's okay may second oh let's
go around the corner hello come back and
talk about it yeah of course um Garrett
anytime you want this is a netflix thing
netflix in june yeah anything else in
May so like amazon hulu all the
streaming google play itunes like
everywhere video on demand may second ok
bo dean did you invite no Russians to
the show this time some smokin dad the
Russians are coming the Russians are
coming he does I'm gonna see him up in
San Francisco hey you say he's gonna
come out to my show I'm gonna tell him I
told him when I saw him out your kids
birthday party yeah i think her whenever
I saw him I like him oh and my
father-in-law likes your dad also
Europeans like each other they do sweaty
Oh swarthy uh worthy funny Mike which
cruise ship can we catch you on uh
crystal symphony in the first week of
june if you happen to be in Bordeaux or
London come on out oh nice at least
you're going to some good places no yeah
I can't wait for that that's exciting
i'm gonna stay later in june and i think
and just kind of oh sweet hang all right
cool yeah I made all my announcements up
front at Marie V on Twitter come check
out these guys when they come to your
down very funny thanks for listening
guys thanks for coming over you too
thank you
it's very welcome you're not an end to
show Karen do not end um spasiba what is
that let's thank you all right life on
the road it says taco tangra course
representing guns and these flights
canceled flights wedding with the runs
turn black this bounced checks great a
bachelorette bumps in the front making
out for yourself and it likes doing blow
more missing merge turn tribal rental
car has another megachurch turn juice
keys vagina fisted cell phone is gone
one big law and order
Oh
uh
you